the new eylem ultra revolution from
touch biotics is the first upper limb
prosthesis that can be controlled with
an app and students in India created she
or society harnessing equipment lingerie
that delivers 82 shocks and contacts the
local police in order to ward off
attackers Vsauce Kevin here this is mind
blow
after four years micro magic systems is
finally ready to reveal mantis the
biggest all-terrain operational hexapod
in the world that walks on six ground
sensing hydraulic legs the british
robotics firm says the two-ton hexapod
has the ability to manipulate objects
such as this trailer automatically level
while riding and load easily by folding
itself onto a truck bed the big house is
powered by algae created by design firms
splitter work up an SSC when used as a
bio skin during the summer the algae
growth speeds up providing a cooling
effect for the residents while
transferring that extra heat to hot
water systems algae is also harvested
and sent to the technical room where
it's fed into a biomass fuel converter
which provides the remainder of the
building's energy needs making it
self-sufficient a new study creates the
illusion of having a phantom limb in non
amputee people neuroscientists and
Karolinska Institute in Sweden set up
the experiment by having the
participants right arm hidden and then
they touch that arm with a brush and
imitate the same movements with another
brush in midair with in full view of the
participant they discover that within a
minute most participants transfer the
sensation of touch to the area of empty
space where they can only see the brush
move and thereby experience a phantom
limb in order to prove the experiment
worked the scientists would make a
stabbing motion towards the phantom limb
and measure the participants sweat
response to the threat which was
increased during the illusion and they
hope that this leads to insight into
future research on phantom pain in
amputees world record 30 skiers holding
hands and doing a flip
new fossil dinosaur embryo suggests that
baby dinosaurs grew at record rates and
also had the ability to flex their
muscles in preparation for the outside
world the bones had blood vessels which
meant that the tissues were burning
oxygen and growing rapidly and the
structure of the bones give researchers
reason to believe that the embryos were
flexing their legs to strengthen their
muscles Fujitsu laboratories created a
touchscreen interface that connects the
real world with the virtual it
accurately detects the users fingertips
creating an interactive touchscreen for
the real world this allows you to
manipulate paper using a webcam and a
commercial projector with disability
information can be imported as data from
any document by just using your fingers
to select it and they're aiming to
develop a commercial version of this by
2014 students at Virginia Tech College
of Engineering made a LifeFlight
autonomous robotic jellyfish the size
and weight of a grown man at 5 foot 7
inches and 170 pounds it's being
developed for the US Navy and the goal
is to have the robotic jellyfish in
waters around the world with the ability
to leave it in the ocean for weeks or
even months eventually they may have the
ability to clean oil spills monitor the
environment or conduct surveillance the
cave automatic virtual environment is a
fully immersive six-sided room that
projects 3d environments on its walls it
was created by the team at uw-madison
and gives the users the ability to move
virtual objects using muscle activity a
projector and virtual reality glasses
this allows users to exert forces
against things that are created in front
of them the hope is that this will have
rehabilitation applications for those
suffering from injuries strokes or
certain disabilities
finally Festo created bionic op tur a
robotic dragonfly that has mastered the
complex flight characteristics of its
real-life counterpart
I'm gonna leave it with a biped robot
that corrects its balance if you push it
and as always thanks for watching